the problem with medicare-for-all is
that when people say that it's
affordable this isn't affordable to the
person who has the Medicare it is not
affordable to the country in fact it is
so unaffordable to the country that the
state of California was a nutjob leftist
state just refused to even pass Medicare
for all because it would have
immediately doubled death just declaring
things rights does not make them appear
what makes more things appear as a
market-based system that creates more
doctors that creates more medical care
that creates more incentive for people
to join up it is better to treat things
as Goods than is rights because
declaring something a right just means
that you have the right to steal it from
me
but I don't want to steal health
insurance from you I want you to be
healthy that's why I want Medicare for
all just suddenly money in my life
services whose service seemed a little
confused about how health care works and
they're like oh my god it turns out the
healthy subsidize the sick yeah that's
insurance the idea that everybody who's
paying into Medicaid paid for it and now
they get out what they paid in is
obviously not true it is a
redistributive program and to pretend
otherwise is just selling the idea that
all of these socialized medicine
countries have it so much better than we
do particularly in terms of cancer care
is a joke
we are still number one in terms of
five-year cancer survival right here in
the United States there are different
areas where we Excel but then honestly
you're cherry-picking there a one
particular area that we're good overall
we're number 37 that is not a good
result the standard of care is the
entire question when it comes to
single-payer health care but the fact is
that rationing is mandated as soon as
you start having the government run the
health care system and decide what level
of care people get they don't care about
me they don't know my child's name they
don't know my name all they know is how
much I cost Ezekiel Emanuel comes down
and says listen I want to die at 17
right I want to 80 that's fine with me
I'd rather die that well that's good for
him but if I don't want to die at 8 here
I don't want my father to die today it's
none of his damn business
[Applause]
this idea that corporations are paying
the highest tax rate is both again true
and untrue the part that it's true is
hey there's a rate of 35 percent the
part that's not true is they don't
actually pay that there is giant loop
a tax loophole is just a tax deduction
that's available to everyone and some
people take advantage of it and some
people don't the amount of tax revenue
the government right now is trillions
dollar every year that's not a sentence
it is clearly down it top bracket now is
around thirty nine percent it used to be
a ninety-one percent right and our
economy is significantly larger than it
was then and part of that is because of
reductions in taxes over previous
decades well we we tried supply-side
economics hey Kansas how's that working
out for you
there was this myth that for you your
business is doing great okay yeah
for example they hide their money
offshore they do tricks like the double
dutch in that irish sandwich or the
reverse i would end that i would say hey
you know what we've got a 35% rate
here's the new rule you're gonna pay
thirty five percent okay and you're not
allowed to hide your money i don't care
if it's in the cayman islands we're
gonna make that illegal corporations
have you they don't have any of your
interests at heart you are a corporation
TYT CEO it's a corporation you have 80
employees i assume that you're not just
a greedy ass and that you actually would
like to help your your employees from
time to time you seem to be identifying
at higher tax rate in the 1950s with
higher level of growth so if that's the
case why not just tax everybody 100
percent we can have massive growth from
here to eternity of course you have to
find the right balance on all these
issues including taxes so I never said
there's no end to how much you could why
though yeah so so the this leads to know
wait a minute so now look when that's
not to say that that is the right tax
rate for us today and so the exercise of
finding the right tax rate is
[Music]
guys try to follow along okay it's
called logic so what we have to do as a
society is figure out where we can
maximize the most amount of good for for
the country government but not too much
away from us so for example the reason
why when taxes are higher it winds up
being better for the economy is because
it cert recirculates the money so if you
give it to the rich this is hilarious if
you're uneducated please at least don't
don't make it obvious when the middle
class has more money disposable income
they spend it why because they're not
living the lap of luxury they're not
saving it for their yacht so they need
to buy food for their family they need
education for their family so they spend
it and it goes back into the economy if
you just give it in supply-side
economics to the rich and hope that it
trickles down on us eventually decades
later what they wind up doing it with it
is something that it's logical they save
it the problem of Keynesian economics is
that it doesn't even work in theory
because again once you go to the logical
extreme which is remove all of the money
from the rich people who are saving all
their money and give it all the poor
people to buy hamburgers that doesn't
help the economy or spur the economy but
Spurs the economy is the creation of new
products and services and that is only
going to be done by people who have
expendable capital to actually invest in
new products and services that we all
enjoy this is what creates economic
growth you had an investor right when
you start at TYT you were given four
million dollars by Buddy Roemer to start
TYT that's great that's the way business
should work right but that money had
they didn't come from bunch of poor
people buying hamburgers it came from a
very very wealthy guy who gave you money
to create a business a lot of people
want to patronize if you want better
products and better services you need
more investment in the products and
services the basic names trickle-down
economics is not something that any
conservative even proposed it's a
leftist revision of what economics
actually is because you're not giving me
the money it was my money in the first
place
created through voluntary transactions
that I had with others I've not stolen
money from either from anyone neither
have you
and the idea that money has to be
forcibly taken from you and handed to
somebody at the bottom end of the
economic spectrum to somehow jog the
akan
that made John McDonald's but is not
going to jog all of the creation of the
products and services that make all of
our lives much better today than they
were thirty years ago in terms of the
stuff we have access to come on
you were the middle class is struggling
right now and we've turned this into a
Walmart economy where people are getting
$7.25 and that if you're getting around
$10 I think that's about 15,000 a year
so don't like that is serious pain and
difficulties so if you give those people
money it's not like I just want to go
get a hamburger and it's not and taxes
is not stealing from you so you're right
I run a business so in order for people
my employees to get to my company you
know what they have to do they have to
drive on roads okay so it's not stealing
from me to build that road I don't think
anyone argues that we don't need roads
to get to work the problem is that when
you're talking about roads as a
percentage of the budget we are talking
about a tiny tiny tiny percentage of the
federal budget and of the state budget
and even of the local budget so the idea
that you're justifying massive tax rates
on corporations or paper roads is just
intellectually dishonest I think that
the Republicans will definitely pass tax
reform they will do everything they will
move mountains to make sure that those
rich donors and corporations will get
their tax cuts Republicans pass tax cuts
because they're beholden to their donors
okay and Democrats passed tax increases
because the unions give them hundreds of
millions of dollars every year and I
don't see Democrats complain about you
got me there that you use your money to
the Democrats
I mean does it upset you as much as you
know bankers giving money to Republicans
no no corporations give way more than
the unions so look it up you can google
it it's really easy here's the problem
okay TYT i we both have corporations and
we expand upon politics every single day
and we motivate thousands of people
right every day on both sides of the
aisle that is effectively an in-kind
contribution now I you campaigned with
Bernie Sanders did you do it because you
expect it that's fine did you expect did
you do that because you supported Bernie
Sanders or did you do that because you
expected some gimme forty whitey in
return I assume you did it because you
supported Bernie Sanders right yes so
okay so the point that I am making is to
attribute to everyone else bad intent
when it comes to political spending in
politics but to yourself it's totally
fine when it comes to other media
intensities that give in-kind
on a regular basis than their coverage
you say well what's the difference
between your speech and their speech
mine is actually speech and theirs is
money
it's a giant different you spend money
first off so they say no no Supreme
Court says no money is speech now no
monies property it's not speech and so
if money was speech well then if you go
to a hooker and you say oh no officer I
was just talking to her okay money is in
the hot speech again I ask you buddy
roemer gave you four million dollars to
start TYT what did he expect in return
should he not have given you mine was
the money not speech it was just money
after all it's like a hooker I assume so
are you the prostitute out of this world
when you take money from Al Jazeera's
that make you a house tonight that was
an awesome conflation okay we were
talking about money in politics and how
money is not speech when you give it as
a campaign donation and you turn it
around to a business investment you know
in a businessman investment is nothing
new his speech money is money they give
us an investment so because they believe
in our business and you think the
government is in the business of
regulating business so the government is
in the business of regulating business
what would be the problem with the
government telling Buddy Roemer he is
not allowed to invest in your business
no that is no no those are two different
issues no problem no problem
so when the Koch brothers or Bloomberg
or Soros puts in hundreds of millions of
dollars into Elections you think well
you know them because they're good guys
and they want an interest in it they
damn well please buying all those
politicians or you think no the
politicians would never be affected by
hundreds of millions of dollars in
legalized bribes I'm curious what your
opinion on that is do you think that
they're just golly shucks Cheney just
mean well I think you're a lawyer so you
know that bribery requires two parties
to the bribe if I give money to a
politician there must be something in
return if there is no quid pro quo there
is no bribery there's nothing in return
well
the politicians oh no no I think very
often there is something in return but I
want you to point me to the things that
are in return not just say that all
spending on politics ought to be
forbidden except for the young turks
know that this of course that what we
say young turks is super 6-ounce we have
80 million uniques it's wonderful do you
think Bernie Sanders would care more if
you gave him ten thousand dollars or if
you dedicated your entire network to
kissing his ass for an election cycle